ability will not cause a conflict of
interest and states its reasons for the
finding
joint representation of co-defendants
charged in criminal matters by attorneys
from the same law firm is uncommon
there is great concern that there may be
a conflict of interest as income
incompatibility of positions may arise
at any moment
of additional concern michigan rule of
professional conduct 3.7 states
that a lawyer shall not act as advocate
at a trial in which the lawyer is likely
to be a necessary witness
i don't yet know if that rule is
implicated
but i want to be clear that a lawyer
providing representation in this manner
will not be permitted to also testify
these concerns need to be addressed both
in the short term and in the long term
and the event in the event that these
matters go to jury trial
to this end the court is appointing
independent counsel for each defendant
the appointment of counsel will not be
as a substitute for the defendant's
current council of choice
or to report back to this court
the purpose of independent counsel
will be for the limited purpose of
advising each defendant in the matter
with regard to joint representation and
the potential for conflicts of interest
the court is aware the defendant is
permitted to make a knowing intelligent
and voluntary waiver of his or her right
to conflict-free counsel
i will be inquiring of each defendant at
our next pre-trial if they intend to
waive any potential conflict
i will also be asking for a written
waiver by each defendant
if it appears that a written waiver by
the defendants becomes necessary
subsequent to their meeting with
independent counsel
i'm requesting the prosecution and
defendants
agreed to language and present a
proposed written waiver
in the meantime i'm going to take the
prosecutor's motion for joint
representation
safeguards which is set for tomorrow
under
advisement
i don't believe the defendants have
responded to that motion
i'm also going to set another pre-trial
date
so i want to ask if you are all
available april 5th at 10 a.m
uh i also want you to keep in mind that
it isn't as easy in the past
to set a court date you probably noticed
that we're not in my courtroom there's a
murder trial going on in my courtroom
and the two adjoining courtrooms so i
can't just
set things without
guesting so
they work for the people
your honor uh i do see that miss smith
has a trial that day in another county
um i can speak with her if you'd like to
schedule it i can speak with her
regarding that trial
okay um
there
are difficulties that we didn't have in
the past moving things around obviously
this case is of great interest to a
great number number of people so there's
a lot of people to notify
um for a pre-trial or any kind of
proceeding the other thing is that i
don't you know i'm sort of homeless
right now i have to you know
kind of look for uh a uh jury room you
know a tr uh courtroom so
that's jury free so
if um for some reason you can't make
that um
we need to know in a timely way because
it's more trouble than it used to be so
i should be able to notify everyone
today your honor okay and if you could
get back to my staff um because we we
could arrange another date
i think i'm going to be in jury trial
next tuesday so
um that would and i don't have a
courtroom so
uh judge just uh one question regarding
the uh written waiver form the people
that attach is an exhibit a proposed um
labor form
and council's response i saw i didn't
see a specific objection counseling
objection to the language in the form of
cash i would prefer that we discuss this
off the record and maybe confer and
decide whether or not we approve of
languages included in the waiter
um i don't think i've seen that because
i don't i don't know if i have that
attachment it probably was filed
um but i i guess i'd like it if you
confer on that i'm
i hope i hope the crumleys understand um
the purpose for the independent council
uh i
i'm concerned that at some point
today
tomorrow
next week
a month from now four months from now
that something could could happen
to cause a conflict
that
could damage your position mr crumley or
your physician mrs crumley
and
i have an obligation to protect your
rights and and i'm concerned
um as we sit here right now that there
there could be a myriad of things
uh
that are incompatible
so
i'm sending appointed counsel
independent counsel and their job isn't
to report back to me
their job isn't to take the place of
your attorney
they're going to talk to you about a
conflict of interest potential conflict
of interest and what would be in your
best interest
so i would urge you to listen to them
and ask them any questions you might
have
because obviously this is very stressful
for everyone involved
i'm trying to avoid
your rights
being implicated in in a negative way
but i'm also trying to avoid
having to uh
recreate or or go backwards with regard
to this case
for example if the matter is in trial
and there's a conflict in the middle of
a trial that could cause a mistrial
um i'm sure it's no surprise to you that
the court is very backed up i happen to
have a
fairly reasonable docket
but
some of the judges in the courthouse are
trying cases
uh where individuals have been in jail
700 days
and and that would not be my intent if
your matter goes to trial i i would give
you the speediest trial possible
however if there's a mistrial because
because of some conflict that arises
during the trial we'd be back at square
one so i want to avoid all of that all
right so um
you should be visited um within uh the
next two weeks
and they'll talk to you
about these issues um
your lawyers might also have uh
physicians with regard to this
you know now there's there's the
preliminary examination transcript is
available and discovery and that could
uh make a difference in in what you
choose going forward
all right
anything else just procedurally so we
understand the court will appoint
independent counsel council will meet
with
the friendly separately separately two
separate lawyers six or seven lawyers
and that is in the presence only of the
independent attorney with the defendant
microgravity absolutely absolutely the
independent lawyer
will be there
with mrs crumley and a separate
independent lawyer will be with mr
crumley absolutely judge and i'll work
with opposing counsel we'll put together
a form and consent
i'd appreciate that i you know if at the
next court date i you know i'll uh
be wanting to move forward and i'll be
asking both sides uh what kind of
motions they might have to file
okay
anything else
nothing from the defense right all right
so so these because you dispose of the
other promotion that tomorrow's date is
off correct that's correct um i hope ms
smith feels better
thank your honor i appreciate that all
right thank you
all right
up
recording stopped
you